en vísperas de la Navidad ortodoxa
Vladimir Putin ha ordenado a sus
militares un alto el fuego teniendo en
cuenta el llamado the kiril el
presidente ordena por la presente al
ministro de defensa de la federación
rusa que imponga un régimen de alto el
fuego a lo largo de toda la línea de
contacto en Ucrania desde la medianoche
del seis de enero hasta la medianoche
del 7 de enero la orden de una tregua de
36 horas siguió un llamado del jefe de
la iglesia ortodoxa rusa el patriarca
quiril el jueves por la mañana Putin
pidió Ucrania que le correspondiera pero
kiev rechazó inmediatamente la petición
calificándola de hipocresía una postura
compartida por muchos ucranianos
creo que esto es una hipocresía total el
31 de diciembre no había Paz estuvimos
sometidos a muchos bombardeos en
nochevieja es pura hipocresía por parte
de Putin
la medida llega a pocos días después de
que un gran número de tropas rusas
murieran en un ataque ucraniano en la
ciudad de mackibzka el día de año nuevo
los analistas creen que La tregua podría
por tanto ayudar a Rusia a evitar otra
gran pérdida de vidas en otra festividad
importante también podría como expresó
el presidente Joe biden que el kremlin
Busca ganar tiempo
soy reacio responder a cualquier cosa
que diga Putin me pareció interesante
que estuviera dispuesto a bombardear
hospitales y guarderías e Iglesias el
día 25 y en año nuevo creo que está
intentando encontrar algo de oxígeno
[Música]
los expertos han afirmado que el alto el
fuego podría utilizarse como una
herramienta Útil para demonizar a
Ucrania ya que como los ucranianos
rechazaron la propuesta
Moscú podría afirmar que kiev no respeta
a los creyentes religiosos y no tiene
ningún deseo de paz